Yeah.
Really Nice drive up there,
Austin.
I can tell you've been working on for your heart,
for that scholar.
Really
just keep doing whatever it is you're doing.
All right.
Okay.
Sorry.
Good out there,
man.
Secret what?
Ah,
nothing.
Okay.
Well,
hey a team dinner tonight at my place.
You come in.
Um,
no.
I'm going to drop this off and let me get some more practice in this practice
for two and a half hours.
This.
Yeah,
but I heard this,
this gal coming.
You've got to be on top of my game.
You know I need that scholarship.
Well,
alright,
come after.
You'll be starving since you never eat.
And my mom is making our pasta.
Yeah.
Okay,
sure.
Fine.
I'm either cool.
Sweet.
All right.
Hey
Jason,
what are you doing here?
I don't know.
He never showed up.
Didn't answer any of my calls or my texts that I could find you here and this,
the dinner.
Okay,
so what,
what does it even matter to you?
Seriously,
my bad for Karen.
Hey.
All right man,
let's stop.
Stop.
Dude.
I'm fine.
Okay.
I don't need a babysitter.
You don't look fine.
I've got it under control.
Okay.
Yeah.
Hey,
I'm going to be straight up.
Do you need help?
Whatever it is you're doing to yourself,
it's not worth it.
Right?
All Right,
gentlemen,
now you're in for a treat today.
Time trials.
This.
Have everybody up on the blocks here.
No,
it'll be worth it.
Swimmers.
Take your mark.
Okay.
It's
okay.
Hey,
what is this anyway?
Leave me alone please.
I don't think you understand what just happened.
Yes,
actually I do.
Oh,
really?
Yes.
Yeah.
I just lost everything.
Everything that I've worked for as a swimmer gone.
Okay.
You know,
I spend every day,
if you're waking hour at this pool and I swim more laps,
then every member of this team combined.
Okay.
You know how much I needed the scholarship?
Do you know damn well what it's been like for me at home?
All I had left a swimming.
You just don't get it.
Is that all that matters to you?
You got some swimming machine?
All right,
man.
You're a person,
a friend,
someone who has cared for,
but right now I can't even tell who you are.
Tony,
get something to eat.
Yeah.
Oh.